hello I'm a visit which as you watch the
Prime Minister of Thailand i'm here if
that was we are addressing a number of
significant challenges we are all facing
not just the economy but also the issues
of food security climate change and
other issues to me what's really
important is that all these issues
cannot be solved by governments or even
by the government and business alone we
need the engagement of civil society of
ordinary people we need everybody to be
aware of the common challenges that we
face and I very much like to invite you
to participate at whatever forum at
whatever convenience of you getting they
have so that we all work together
towards a better world to achieve peace
and prosperity for all of us thank you